wie gespalten ist denn ihre Partei
sie ist überhaupt nicht gespalten
sondern sie ist pluralistisch und ich
bin sehr stolz darauf Herr Kiesewetter
dass wir nicht nur unser Partei sondern
auch in der Fraktion verschiedene
Meinungen zulassen vielleicht auf die
Beschönigung von Kriegsverbrechen eine
so bösartige Unterstellung hätte ich ihn
gar nicht zugetraut aber konzentriert
wir kommen beide aus einer gleichen
Ausbildung und Erziehung die sollte uns
das eigentlich verbieten mal etwas ich
finde Tradition von 20 Juli 44 und
Freiheitskriege das eben nicht mir zu
unterstellen ist nicht fair und ist auch
es unter der Pluralismus es ist nicht
Pluralismus kein Angriff an sie es ist
nicht Pluralismus einer Partei
Kriegsverbrechen zu beschönigen oder
dass ein Eugen Schmidt öffentlich sagt
in Deutschland gibt es keine Freiheit
[Musik]